- Let's close things out
with something that
might make us all smile.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
You all know Danielle Kartes.
We've had her on many, many times.
She's taught us how to
make overflowing lava cake,
the Olive Garden's pasta fagioli.
She's even shown us secrets
to dining al fresco.
Danielle seriously
works some magic, y'all.
Now she's got her own vodka
line called Fluorescence.
This is a woman who
chases the right dreams.
We have Danielle on the line right now
watching on KOMO 4 at 2:00 PM in Seattle.
What's up, Danielle!
(crowd cheering)
- Hi.
Oh my gosh. I'm so excited to see you.
This is so good.
- [Kelly] I'm very excited.
I think I have a drink right
here, so it's great to see you.
That's so cool.
So what made you want
to launch a vodka brand?
And thank you.
- Oh my gosh. I know this is so cool.
So it's called Fluorescence,
which means to be in bloom.
- [Kelly] Oh?
- And I think that we are 40,
you and I both turned 40 this year.
It was really important
for me to create something,
first of all, that didn't
taste like gasoline.
I feel like we needed
something that was delicious
and flavorful.
It's grapefruit and pomelo.
Is that not the most
delicious cocktail ever?
- Like, you missed my
actual initial reaction
- [Danielle] It's the smoothest.
- It's so good.
- Yep.
It's so good.
And it took two years to formulate this.
I partnered with one of our
clients, Heritage Distilling.
We came up with a beautiful
vodka that's all natural.
It tastes wonderful.
And it speaks to women like you and me.
I feel like everything is
marketed to 20-somethings,
and I'm like, we're in
the prime of our lives.
We are flourishing.
We're doing drop off.
We're running empires.
And I want women to chase their dreams.
You don't have to have all
the means in the world.
You just got to get out there
and get a vodka line going.
Okay?
(laughing)
(crowd clapping)
- That is some great advice.
Thank you Danielle, as always.
We love you so much here.
This is dang good.
I'm liking your post right now
and I'm enjoying your drink
constantly.
- Thank you.
To being in bloom.
- Absolutely. Okay.
So usually this is the point
when we give our guest money,
courtesy of Pilot Pen Makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson show.
Ding.
But come on.
Danielle's got all her cookware,
she's got a vodka line.
She don't need money.
So today we're giving
someone in the audience
a thousand dollars from Pilot Pen.
So the check is under someone's chair.
So who got it?
Who got it?
(drum roll)
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Yeah!
Stand up!
It's me. It's me
- Stand up. Stand up.
What's your name? Where are you from?
- My name is Kimberly Kay
and I'm from St. George, Utah.
(crowd clapping)
- Okay. Well this is for you.
What you gonna do with that money?
- I don't know something.
(crowd laughing)
- Oh my God, I love you so much!
Well have some fun with it.
Congratulations.